[موسيقى]
الفودو
مانويل ج 6 السيد زميله 2 للبطل
نعم
عين
[موسيقى]
نعم ، اسمي كينتارو ساكاي
مهنتي هي إنتاج وبيع Nishikigoi في محافظة هيروشيما.
هذا Nishiki-koi رهيب ، لكن أسلافي من Dairei
الطريقة الأولى التي تعلمت بها كيفية تنمية هذا النوع من الأشياء كانت من والدي. إنه أمر طبيعي حقًا.
أعني أنني توليت هذه الوظيفة الآن
حسنًا ، إنه من هذا القبيل
لزج
يوجد حوالي 70 نوعًا من Nishiki-koi في الغرفة وعند تقسيمها إلى قطع صغيرة.
نوع Nishikigoi الذي أفعله هو الأحمر والأبيض
حسنا الحب الأبيض أكاتسو وتايشو سانشوكو أحمر أسود وأبيض
هذه الأصناف الثلاثة فقط
إنه مثل هذا
سيستمر التكاثر الطبيعي في الحياة لمدة 20 إلى 30 عامًا
ومع ذلك ، فإن ذروة الجمال لا تزال تبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات.
أيضا
حبي هو النظام الأول
شخصية رائعة
وهو لامع
مشروع bd 6 d يبحث عن بيع صفحة رياضية
نورماد r burst harakara حمام أرضي 2 رو برو 4
رو
بالحديث عن العنصر المهم للجرو شيكو ، بعد كل الماء
بعد كل شيء كيف تصنع المياه الصالحة للشرب وكيف
إن صنع الطعام اللذيذ وإعطائه للعمل هو العامل الأكثر أهمية.
[موسيقى]
نيشيكي كوي لها طعم متطور للغاية.
أنا أفهم أن هذا الطعم لذيذ وسيء.
4 تولد من جديد للقيام بسمكة الزفاف
فقط الدم
mdb 2 Saazun Fish يوصى به donde للقيام بالنجمة
الجسم هذا شكل الجسم رائع
أيضًا ، يصبح لمعان نسيج اللون مهمًا جدًا.
ملكة جمال لأول مرة عام 2000 حتى 2020 هذا العام 10 مرات
أخذت البطل
rds لسعيد لا تفعل n غرام
بوو
لي بعض السراويل bnx الاسمية ب
حسنًا ، إنها الأسطورة ، التي فازت بالبطولة في بطولة All Japan العام الماضي.
Koide هذا الصوت يذهب إلى ذلك المزاد
إنه حب 203 مليون يمان سجل رقمًا قياسيًا عالميًا جديدًا ، لكن هذا الحب لا يزال حبًا جيدًا
حقل الأرز
من المهم أن تربح ، ولكن من هؤلاء العملاء
حسنًا ، إذا وصل صوت سعيد ، فسيكون صوتًا آخر
هل هو شعور بالإنجاز يؤدي إلى الشعور بالرضا.
بعد كل شيء ، بالنسبة لي ، الحفل يشبه طفلي.
عندما أرى الأطفال يكبرون ويصبحون جميلين ، يكون الأمر كذلك حقًا
أنا سعيد
[موسيقى]